This video is brought to you by Ray cotton.
Hello wise, correct. Helen here,
beaming to you from the comfort of my apartment.
A lot of people talk about being productive during quarantine writing books,
making short films, reading all the classics, and you've done calculus,
but I have them all beat because during this time I have immersed myself in the
greatest cultural catalog of them. All. Netflix, I have studied everything.
This great purveyor of entertainment has put out, but there's one show.
I was most excited to sit on my couch and kill half a day.
Watching space force the show seemingly had everything going for it.
Its creator Greg Daniels had already made not one but two modern TV classics.
Plus it featured an amazing cast. Steve Morrell, John Malcovich,
Jane Lynch, Fred Willard, Lisa Kudrow, Ben Schwartz,
and Patrick Warburton paired with a ridiculous premise.
I was so hopeful and then it's just a dog
pile of bad press. And I don't think it was just reviewers being out of touch.
This show is in my very scientific end. Not at all arbitrary opinion,
bad, not exactly bright, bad, but still a colossal disappointment.
It left me wondering how could so many talented people produce such a misfire?
How did a tried and true formula go so wrong?
Let's find out in this wisecrack edition on space force, what went wrong,
but before we get into it, I want to give a shout out to Ray con.
If you're thinking about jumping on the Bluetooth bandwagon,
now's the time to take the leap.
One of the greatest hesitations for me was geared bud design.
I don't like the hard shell earbuds because they always fall out of my ears so
easily.
But Ray on earbuds come with different sized gel tips so you can get the most
comfortable fit for your ear. They're snug,
compact and Brie discreet on top of a great fit.
They're more affordable coming in at about half the price of other premium
wireless brands on the market.
And you don't have to compromise on quality because they sound amazing.
Rank on earbuds are perfect from working from home,
working out or just doing chores around the house.
When you need to listen to music or podcasts for hours with the everyday
[inaudible] is their best model. Yet with six hours of playtime seamless,
Bluetooth pairing, more base and a compact design that gives you a nice noise,
isolating fit. Check them out now by going to buy rate con.com/wisecrack,
where by clicking the link in the description,
when you use the link in the description, you'll get 15% off your order.
Now back to the show, first, a quick recap of the series.
The TV series presents a fictionalized account of the U S militaries newest
branch. The space force, as it tries to get boots on the moon by 2024,
Steve Carell stars as general Mark narrowed,
a hard nose general appointed to lead it near to constantly has to balance the
demands of his chest thumping white house superiors.
With those of his scientific team led by Adrian Mallory,
who questions if it's logically or even ethically possible to get back to the
moon on such a tight timeframe, making matters, even worse.
Nerds family life is quickly spiraling out of control.
His wife is in prison and his teenage daughter resents him for being a
workaholic faced with both professional and personal uncertainty.
There's only one place where narrowed can find relief.
Go baby, don't wake up.
Cry.
Space force at its heart gives us two TV shows in one half hourish package.
First, a wacky office sitcom.
I love the office and parks and rec and second a political satire in the vein of
V but by constantly straddling this line space force doesn't quite
succeed as either. So let's break down how it fails on both counts.
Part one, the workplace sit-com. Since the advent of television,
the workplace sit-com has provided an easy to shoot setting for a group of
eccentrics to gather round and crack wise from McHale's Navy to
taxi, to cheers, to ally McBeal, to Archer.
The workplace has served as a backdrop for various characters to both come
together and clash their personality differences,
providing conflict for each episode.
Because these corporate bag Montrece home is $630 for my
God forks or counts.
In comedy.
A geographic and historical guide scholar Marise Charney uses cheers as the
prototypical example of the workplace sitcom.
When he writes it is the most ritualized sit-com format,
as it relies on the repetition of a setting of each character's traits and of
each set of conflicts and alliances,
it presented a set of highly ritualized characters whose personality traits were
extremely fixed and who interacted with one another in the same ways each week,
each episode of cheers is structured pretty much exactly the same revolving
around bartender, Sam Malone,
as he tends bar and deals with patrons and employees,
the workplace AKA the bar became idealized,
not necessarily because of the job itself, but because no matter the problem,
each character could always rely on the people there to have their backs.
Sam was always willing to lend an ear to coach Diane, Carla cliff, norm,
and Frazier. Just take it from the cheers theme song.
Knows your name.
That's true with other workplace comedies of the era and of those that proceeded
sheers on ally McBeal. It was the law firm on taxi, the garage dispatch center.
However, as television age,
the depiction of the workplace on sitcoms became far darker.
Take Greg Daniel's breakout adaptation of the office.
The workplace became an existential prison and the shared experiences characters
bonded over when they bonded or centered around their incompetent and incredibly
offensive boss, Dunder Mifflin is a complete dead end for each character. Jim,
the every man hero of the series hates his job openly stating vet.
Well, if this were my career, I'd have to throw myself.
In front of a train.
Aside from the occasional light of an office romance Dunder Mifflin is marked by
soul crushing monotony.
Yes, he is a run out the plot situation, just Michael.
In season. Two's the office Olympics.
We see how each employee copes with their pointless jobs,
crafting elaborate games for themselves just to pass the time and Dunder
Mifflin. Unlike the bar of cheers,
doesn't seem to bring these eccentrics together. It divides them
While they eventually about face later in the show,
much of the early seasons of the office deal with the antagonistic relationship
between coworkers. For instance, in season ones,
the Alliance after rumors of downsizing begin to spread people at the office
began to form secret packs against women.
There's no downsizing, but if there were right to be protected as a system.
My manager later in the series,
when the employees dare to even think about joining together and unionizing the
Dunder Mifflin higher up squash the comradery threatening to dissolve the branch
completely. If there is even a whiff of unionizing in this branch,
I can guarantee you the branch will be shut down like that.
Dunder Mifflin is repeatedly shown to be a toxic environment.
One in which stupidity and boringness are promoted.
Look no further than Jim's boss, Michael Scott,
who has proven time and time again, to be an impediment to productivity.
Michael claims to have his employee's best interest at heart guilt.
Whenever he feels challenged, he immediately sells them out.
The guys downstairs are thinking about forming a union and they have some good
points.
Union. If you've ever wondered why he hates Toby so much,
it's likely because he's the only person who can challenge his antics.
Miami,
you still can't make fun of people for race or gender or sexual orientation or
religion who let the Lemonhead.
Into the room or consider the time when Jim takes a private meeting with the CFO
and Michael mistakenly thinks this means Jim must be angling for his job to
ensure he doesn't get fired. Michael bad mounts, Jim, to his higher ups,
thereby sabotage Jim's promotion.
Constant office distractions spends way too much time interception antagonize
it. Other salesmen, not at all. What do you think?
How bad is Dunder Mifflin? It's so bad that employment lawyer,
Julie Elgar even started a blog chronicling all the actionable offenses that
occur at the company. And it's over 30 pages long in its later years,
the office softened some of these edges,
many characters ended up marrying their coworkers or forming unlikely
friendships with one another. Yet.
Dunder Mifflin itself always remained the destructive environment in the offices
finale. It's telling that for a vast majority of the characters,
their happy ending involves getting away from this corporate helmet.
Not quite as cheerful as well, cheers,
but also not quite as nightmarish as the office space forces workplace setting
exists somewhere between the two visions. On one hand,
the space force space is located in the desolate wasteland of Colorado,
a place where the only sign of life is a single convenience store patron by meth
gangs.
It's so bad that when narrative first tells his wife where they're moving,
she immediately breaks down in tears,
Colorado like Dunder Mifflin is depicted as a dead end for narrative.
His family.
When the series jumps ahead a year in the opening episode near his wife is now
literally behind bars for unexplained reasons.
And his daughter has no friends or job prospects to speak of narrowed himself
feels trapped.
His momentous promotion to a four-star general is quickly undercut as he becomes
the four star general of a branch considered a joke amongst his peers.
For space force. First time with your Keester in the hot seat. My peer last.
And yet the space force space stands in strong contrast to these immediate
surroundings, hidden behind a Rocky mountain.
The base is a luxurious high-end campus,
spacious green and pristine. Heck they even have an ice cream stand.
So is narrowed stuck in a dead end job?
Or is this the opportunity of a lifetime?
Well space force can't really decide one way or the other.
Sometimes the series is very critical of narrative job and his attempts to
militarize space. After space force,
a satellite is caught apart by a rival Chinese satellite near proposes that they
use a bomb to push the broken pieces back together.
In my experience with the air force, that was very often the right answer. Very,
very often.
Of course,
Mallory shoots the idea down because the phone won't work in the vacuum of
space. All right.
Can bomb. That was my first instinct. Anyway, that's no better shockwaves.
It's a vast place.
Thus,
the idea of implementing traditional military techniques is depicted not only as
wrong, but as completely absurd in the office,
Daniels really explored what it meant to be in a dying pointless industry,
a place where your average employee can only ask the basic question why,
and it seems like a similar opportunity with space force.
Whereas the office explored the waning paper industry,
spaceports explores the waning of American head Geminis.
And Eric, if you need any help, getting back to the Chinese, what to do,
you satellite a little ground in bound, whatever.
I don't know, let me know rains at your disposal.
And even if the space force itself isn't obsolete,
it certainly seems frivolous to many.
The show takes some strides in this direction.
Basically reducing the conflict between China and the U S as a childish contest,
mostly involving vandalism,
but the series pretty quickly backs off the U S actually is in a military
standoff with the Chinese for space dominance Daniels,
even stated that the more he researched space force,
the more sense the department actually made.
The more research that we did into it,
the more it didn't feel like the problem was all in the heads of people in the
United States,
because there's people in Russia and China and elsewhere scrambling to get up
there. Unlike Dunder Mifflin, where the job was in and of itself,
completely pointless.
Working at the space force is treated as an integral and worthwhile vocation.
So the series is stuck in a strange middle ground,
both highly critical of the military station of space,
and also treating it like a necessity,
which makes that tire more difficult to be fair.
This middle ground was masterfully tread in parks and rec, uh,
showed that skewer, dysfunctional local politics.
The slogan should be Pawnee home of crackers.
The oranges goldfish in Indiana.
Well ultimately championing local politician, Leslie, for her perseverance.
But the viewpoint of the show unlike space force was clear.
The democratic process is messy, overly, bureaucratic,
and dominated by rich idiots,
but we can still try to turn a giant pit into a park.
It just might take a few years.
We present the crown jewel of Pawnee.
Even more space force is missing a key ingredient that made the office parks and
rec cheers, and pretty much every sit-com ever made work,
the straight man or woman on cheers.
It was bartender Sam Malone for the office,
Jim Halpert for parks and rec Mark and Anne.
These characters served as audience surrogates for the series,
the every man or woman reacting to the crazy hi-jinks that happen around them on
the office, white,
Michael and Angela could be as insane and off-color as needed.
But then you could always count on the camera panning over to Jim,
shaking his head in the music. However, with space force,
there really isn't a traditional straight man.
Narrowed is technically our entryway into the show.
The point of view character yet space force constantly distances us from him by
depicting him as a blustering idiot.
It's narrowed that tries to use a monkey to fix a broken satellite and later
accuses one of his scientists of being a Chinese spy based solely on his race.
Chan Devin Ali Chan is mine. Number two,
I consider him above suspicion. All right, so we've got URI Baxter.
In these instances, the series cuts to Malcovich is Adrian Mallory.
As he shakes his head and amusement. So is Mallory the every man,
not quite while he balances neared, he oozes pretension.
Mallory's even more eccentric than Baird.
A self-centered hothead set off by anyone who doesn't take him seriously without
a straight man or woman.
The characters on space force constantly beer between oscillating extremes.
Sometimes narrowed is upheld as a beacon of virtue.
Someone the audience should sympathize with and relate to.
Founder of the space force. That's going to be me while.
Other times he does this. You're overheating.
As weakness.
Ironically,
this is a problem Greg Daniels has dealt with before on parks and rec. Sure.
Mark and Anne offered balanced to Leslie's antics,
but they weren't quite central to the show. Just take it from Daniel's himself.
But parks and rec didn't really hit until season two.
The big adjustment was that Amy Poehler was funnier being the smart center of a
crazy world than somebody whose character flaws caused their own problems.
I would say by three or four episodes, we had fixed that.
I think personally it wasn't until parks and rec created a straight woman out of
Amy Poehler's lesbian. Nope, but the show was able to find its footing.
And even when she got a little too into binders and waffles,
she was grounded with the downtown earthiness of someone like an however space
for still hasn't found that balance yet.
But this balance is only half the story because besides being a workplace comedy
space force is also trying to be a political satire.
Part two political satire justice space force is wishy-washy about its
depiction of workplace antics. It's also, wishy-washy about it. Satire.
According to Daniel's space force is supposed to be a commentary on how the
idealism of space has been co-opted by militaristic nationalism.
What was once about the idealistic pursuit of human excellence?
Well, I'm all for LAN
purveyor.
It has instead become all about national and military dominance.
According to Daniels, I think the show's feeling is more that it's too bad.
We're now in this new phase of space exploration where it isn't about doing it
for all mankind, in some moments, space force,
really nails the satirical point.
Back hard. We can bomb big bomb, little bomb, bomb, stupid bomb.
There's one for every occasion.
Yet at the same time,
space force constantly pulls its punches on a biting set tire like beep the show
takes no prisoners. Every subject, every political movement is open to ridicule,
whether liberal or conservative, rather than attacking a political faction,
the show puts the entire political process on blast.
The lead to think he's in here leading, but he's not.
He is according to the room, right?
Space force.
On the other hand wants to be a satire of America's militaristic nationalism
without letting itself be too mean to the institution at the center of it as
such space force lacks, any specific perspective,
militarizing space is both absurd and a necessity general narrative is both a
great man and a total buffoon.
The job is both noble and a dead end space force wants to have it every which
way. And in the process it says nothing at all.
Just look at how the series treats its central antagonistic relationship,
Mark narrative versus Adrian Mallory. In many ways,
this relationship is a mirror image of our favorite local government odd couple
in parks and rec.
The central antagonistic relationship was between Leslie Knope and Ron
Swanson. Leslie represented the textbook liberal.
She earnestly believed that Republic service.
She could help fix the wrongs of the world and build a better tomorrow.
When we worked here together,
we fought scratched and clawed to make
people's lives a tiny bit better. That's what public service is all about.
However, Leslie's boss Ron represented the textbook libertarian.
He believed the government should be virtually nonexistent.
The idea of a perfect government is one guy who sits in a small room at a
desk. And the only thing he's allowed to decide is who to nuke.
As such bond supported,
minimizing the parks and rec departments output by hiring people who would do as
little as possible.
Like Tom, he doesn't do a lot work around here. He shows zero initiative.
It's not a team player. He's never wanting to go that extra mile.
Tom is exactly what I'm looking for in a government employee.
Now naturally you would expect Leslie and Ronda butt heads and yes,
oftentimes they did.
Whoop me want more pointless social programs, yummy, yummy, yummy.
But as the series grew,
the show focused less on the antagonism between the two and more of their
unlikely friendship, despite their political differences.
Ron and Leslie genuinely cared for one another and help each other,
both professionally and personally as such parks and rec used Ron and Leslie's
relationship to present an idealized form of government.
One in which people from opposing party lines could still come together to get
things done. Just take it from Amy Poehler.
The show is about the fact that there's a lot of people who work together who
have nothing in common, except for the fact that they worked together.
That really describes to me national politics,
people who have nothing in common,
except for the fact that they've worked together and have to find a way to work
together and make change happen. Similarly,
on space force narrowed and Mallory represent opposite ends of the ideological
spectrum.
Mallory embodies a kind of small liberal intelligence SIA or as narrowed is
you're ignorant and blustery military man.
What used to be known in America as a man.
But unlike parks and rec space force,
doesn't use this contrast in relationship to comment on any larger issues.
Instead, it's just kind of all over the place.
Sometimes Mallory is used as an obstacle for Nair to overcome. For instance,
in the pilot, Mallory keeps trying to underhandedly postpone narrowed,
satellite watch saving the scientific dangers of doing so prematurely.
But by the end of the episode,
narrow follows his gut and successfully launches the satellite proving Mallory's
objections to be unfounded. However, in later episodes near its gut,
military instincts are liability and it's Mallory's cautious reasoning that
saves the day and episode five narratives only able to defeat the rival air
force his team in a test skirmish because of Mallory's Deus ex Machina code
space force seems unsure of what side it's on Mallory's intellectual realism or
narrative jingoism.
It basically becomes a toss up each episode on who will be proven, right as if,
since narrowed won the day. Last episode. Now it's Mallory's term to do so.
And if the ultimate point is that both men end up rubbing off on one,
another creating a new middle ground. Well spaceports,
doesn't present that traditional arc either. Instead by the final episodes,
both men suddenly shift perspectives out of the blue after space force discovers
that the Chinese have established a base on the moon it's Mallory who thinks
they need to take a more decisive militaristic approach.
What if your friend who runs the Navy word to move a
carrier strike group or not to carrier strike groups
into the South China sea, right?
Snared wants to try a more diplomatic route and speak to the Chinese general.
Sometimes it's important that cooler heads prevail.
Thus the character don't even attempt to come to a middle ground.
They simply switch ideologies based on well plucked.
The closest space force comes to making a clear political point happens in the
last episode after narratives ordered by his white house superiors to burn the
Chinese moon base to the ground. He enlists Mallory to help defy this order.
Nair then gives the following speech.
How bad polio was. People stopped taking vaccines,
forget how bad world Wars are. People start puffing out their chest.
The real enemy is arrogance.
This seems to be the ultimate point of space force that both Mallory and
narrative arrogance often blind them to the correct course of action.
If only both characters and the world at large could put their egos aside,
then the real work could be done and get nothing in the previous nine episodes
shows this point to be true because it's narrative arrogance in the pilot that
his gut knows better than science that saves the day. And it's,
Mallory's perceived intellectual superiority that allows the space force to
defeat the air force in their skirmish.
All space forces proven up to now is that narrowed and Mallory should be staunch
in their beliefs in case they're accidentally, right?
Ultimately space force twist itself so much to a piece.
Every side that it forgets to say anything interesting or really anything much
at all. However, it's not all doom and gloom.
The first seasons of the office and parks and rec were similarly fraught with
issues before reversing course to become two of the most beloved modern sitcoms.
So if anyone can write this ship, especially with such a great cast,
it's Greg Daniels, but what do you think?
Are we just cranky because space force,
has it lived up to the greatness of its predecessors or is it legitimately bad?
Let us know what you think in the comments. Big, big,
thanks to our awesome patrons for supporting our channel and podcasts and as
always, thanks for watching.
[Inaudible].